[Music]
charlotte north carolina veronica is
with us hey veronica how are you
hi bro hi it's dave sorry thanks for
taking my call how are you great how can
we help um yeah so i'm newly married um
my husband and i
we have debt because i went to college
um didn't know any better and got myself
into debt um however i've been paying
off my debt snowball now for at least i
guess a year and a half two years now
my husband and i we yeah
my husband and i we recently got married
uh when i met him he was
on
route to be to become a chiropractor so
it takes about 10 years to become a
chiropractor he's pretty much in the
middle of that um so he's paid it off so
far
cash
but now we're married he has debt you
know because he married me
and then we have a fully funded
emergency fund and so we're kind of
in a bind wondering
what we should do
with
um the money that we
would put into debt should we continue
putting that into the debt or should we
save it um should we put it in an
investment vehicle for
uh for his schooling
we're kind of
not sure what to do right now the first
step of
avoiding of getting out of debt is
avoiding new debt
so you have to manage your cash to go to
school
without it without any debt
that's your first goal yeah whatever's
left over after you manage your cash to
go to school
whatever's left over you can pay on the
debt
okay but it'd be crazy for you to pay
off your student loan debt him turn
around borrow to be a chiropractor
you're just swapping hands
yeah 100
yeah so no need to do that we're just
going to slow
the debt reduction on yours
enough to cash flow his chiropractic
school is that am i answering this is
this what you're asking
yeah yeah um i'm
i another thing we were thinking about
and i don't know if it would be too late
considering that he's already in school
but we've considered
maybe like asas or 529 plans or
something like that i don't know
um i don't know too much about it no i
don't think that's necessary because
it's not a
those work best when you have a long
time horizon because they grow tax-free
but if you're gonna leave it in there a
year tax-free growth is not relevant
yeah okay veronica you mentioned savings
uh you mentioned emergency fund are you
talking about our baby step one one
thousand dollars or is there more in
there
oh no it's the the baby step one okay
emergency fund okay so you don't have
any additional cash that you guys have
saved up right now
no we have put it all
into debt or into school yeah when it
all goes into school first and then if
there's anything left it goes on your
debt and make sure if you do need to
pull some back through the summer to get
ready for the fall that's allowed
because that's just cash management to
go to school but we're not gonna pile up
like a hundred thousand dollars in a
savings account just so we can make sure
he goes to school that's not
what we're suggesting here but but you
guys gotta just look out into the future
look at your income versus your outgo
and go okay here's how we're gonna cash
flow this and
any spillover then you throw it at the
next thing at the at the dead is what
we're gonna do
so good question